let's say we observe some object let's
say for the sake of argument it's
happening in space and it's traveling in
a circular path with the magnitude of
its velocity being constant and i want
to be very clear here because the
magnitude so let me draw its velocity
vector so that is the length of this
arrow is the magnitude of its velocity
but i want to be clear in order for it
to be traveling in a circular path the
direction of its velocity needs to be
changing so at this time it might the
velocity vector might look like that
after a few seconds the velocity vector
let me do that in a different color so
we can keep track of things after a few
seconds the velocity vector might look
like this
after another few seconds the velocity
vector might look like this i'm just
sampling
from i obviously could have sampled
after less time and it would have been
right over there but i'm just sampling
sometimes as it travels around the
circle after a few more seconds the
velocity vector the velocity vector
might look something like that and what
i want to do is think about what needs
to happen what kind of force would have
to act and in particular the direction
of the force that would have to act on
this object in order for its velocity
vector to change like this and let's
remind ourselves if there was no force
acting on this body and this comes
straight from newton's first law of
motion then the velocity would not
change neither the magnitude nor the
direction of the velocity would change
so if there were no force acting on this
object it would just continue going on
in the direction it was going it
wouldn't it wouldn't curve it wouldn't
turn the direction of its velocity
wasn't changing so let's think about
what what the direction of that force
would have to be and to do that i'm
going to copy and paste these
these velocity vectors and we can keep
track of what the change in velocity or
especially the direction of the change
in velocity has to be
so let's say copy and let me paste that
so that is our first velocity vector let
me scroll a little bit
to the right
so that's our first velocity vector let
me copy all of these this is our second
one right over here
this is our second one
let me copy and paste it
so
i'm i'm just looking at it from the
object's point of view what how does the
velocity vector change from each of
these points in time to the next and
then let me get all of these in there
so then let me get this green one
and it looks like that
so let me copy and let me paste it
go put it like that
and then let me do and i could keep
going i could keep drawing velocity
vectors around this circle but let me do
this orange one right over here
so
copy and then paste so do just like that
so between this purple time
and this let me do this in let me do it
in white between this purple time right
over here and this and i guess this
magenta time and this purple time what
was the change in velocity well we can
look at that purely from these vectors
right here the change in velocity
between those two times was that right
over there
that is our change in velocity so if we
were to take this vector this little
white vector that i did and said okay
what was it what in what direction was
the velocity changing when the object
was going on this part of the arc well
it was roughly if i were to just if i
were to just translate that vector right
over here it's roughly going in that
direction so that is the direction of
our change in velocity this triangle is
delta delta is for change now let's
think about the next little time period
between this blue or purple period and
this green period our change in velocity
would look like that
change in velocity so while it's
traveling along this part of the arc
roughly it's the change in velocity if
you if we if we draw the vector starting
at the object it would look something
like this i'm just translating actually
do it a little bit
it looks something like this i'm just
translating this vector this vector to
right over here and then i'll just do it
one more time and let me do it in this
blue color so from this green point in
time to this orange point in time and
obviously we're just sampling points
it's continuously moving and the change
in velocity is actually continuously
changing but hopefully you're going to
see a pattern here so between those two
points in time this is our this right
here is our
this right here is our change in
velocity and so if i were to translate
that vector right over there it would
look something like that change in
velocity so what do you see and if i
were to if i were to keep drawing more
of these change in velocity vectors you
would see at this point the change in
velocity would have to be going
generally in that direction if at this
point the change in velocity would be
having to go generally in that direction
so what do you see what's the pattern
for any point along this circular curve
what's the pattern well the change in
velocity is first of all it is
perpendicular to the direction of the
velocity itself
and we haven't proved it but it at least
looks like it it looks like this is
perpendicular and even more interesting
it looks like it's seeking the center
the change in velocity is constantly
going in the direction of the center of
our circle
the center of our circle
and we know from newton's first law that
if the if the velocity is changing and
if the magnitude could stay the same but
if the velocity is changing in any way
either the magnitude or the direction or
both there must be a net force acting on
the object and the net force is acting
in the direction of the acceleration
which is causing the change in velocity
so the force must be acting in the same
direction as this change in velocity so
in order to make this object go in this
circular path there must be some force
some force causing kind of pulling the
object towards the center and a force
that is perpendicular to its direction
of motion and this force is called the
centripetal force
centripetal
not to be confused with centrifugal
force very different centripetal force
centra you might recognize that means
the center and then petal is comes from
it's seeking the center so let me write
that it is center
it is center
it is center seeking and so this
centripetal force something is pulling
on this object towards the center that
causes it to go in this circular motion
and that's that inward pulling causes
inward acceleration so that's
centripetal force
a centripetal force
causing
causing centripetal acceleration
acceleration which causes the object to
go towards the center the whole point
why i did this is at least it wasn't
intuitive to me that if you have this
object going in a circle that the change
in velocity the acceleration the force
acting on this object would actually
have to be center or it would have to be
towards the center the whole reason why
i drew these vectors and then translated
them over here and then drew these
change in velocity vectors is to show
you that the change in velocity is
actually towards the center of this body
now or towards the center of the circle
now with that out of the way you might
say well where does this happen in in
everyday life or actually i guess in
reality in some way shape or form and
the most typical example of this and
this is something that i think most of
us have done when we were kid is if you
had a yo-yo
if you have a yo-yo
my best attempt to draw a yo-yo
if you have a yo-yo and if you whip it
around on a string if you whip it around
on a string you know that the yoyo goes
in a circular
it goes it goes in a circle
it goes in a circle even though its
speed might be constant or another way
of thinking about speed the magnitude of
its velocity might be constant we know
that the direction of its velocity is
constantly changing it's going in a
circle and what's causing it to go in a
circle is your hand right over here
pulling on this string and providing
tension into that string
so there's a force the centripetal force
in this yoyo example is the tension in
the string that is constantly pulling on
the yoyo towards the center and that is
why that yoyo goes in a circle another
example that you are probably somewhat
familiar with or at least have heard
about is if you have if you have
something in orbit around a planet so
let's say that this is earth right here
this is earth right here and you have
some type of a you have some type of a
satellite let me draw a satellite you
have some type of a satellite that is in
orbit
that is in orbit around earth that
satellite
that satellite has some velocity at any
given moment in time but what's keeping
it from not flying out into space and
keeping it going in a circle is the
force of gravity so in the example of in
the example of a satellite or actually
anything in orbit even the moon in orbit
around the earth the thing that's
keeping it in orbit as opposed to flying
out into space is the centripetal force
of earth's gravity now another example
and this is probably the most everyday
example because we do it all the time
if you imagine a car
traveling around a racetrack so let me
draw a racetrack right around here
if i have a racetrack and i before i
tell you the answer i'll have you think
about it so let me draw my best attempt
at a racetrack
let me just draw a circular i'm not
going to even bank the racetracks let's
look at the racetrack from above
so if i have a car on a racetrack i want
you and pause this before i tell it to
you because i think it's an interesting
thing to think about because it seems
like a very obvious
thing that's happening we've all
experienced we've all taken turns in
cars so that we're looking at the top of
a car that's its tires
we're looking at the top of a car and
when you see a car going at a constant
speed so on the speedometer it might
just say whatever 60 miles an hour or 40
miles an hour whatever the constant
speed but it's traveling in a circle
it's traveling in a circle
so what is keeping what is the
centripetal force in that example
there's there's no obvious string being
pulled on the car towards the center
there's no some magical gravity pulling
it towards the center of the circle
there's obviously gravity pulling it
down towards the ground but nothing
pulling it to the side like this so
what's keeping this car what's causing
this car to go in the circle as opposed
to going
straight and i encourage you to pause it
right now before i tell you the answer
so assuming you've now unpaused it i
will now tell you the answer the thing
that's keeping it going in the circle is
actually the force of friction it's
actually it's actually the force between
the the the that resists movement to the
to the side between the tires and the
road and a good example of that is if
you were to remove the friction of the
road if you were to make the car drive
on oil or on ice or if you were to if
you were to shave the treads of the tire
if it was some type of a plastic tire or
something then a car would not be able
to do this so it's actually the force of
friction in this example so i encourage
you
to think about that